in my last video we performed an
experiment in which two identical wood
blocks were shot with the same rifle one
through the center of mass and the other
one slightly off to one side now if you
haven't seen that video yet then click
here now and go and watch it or if
you're on a mobile device click the link
in the description so the question was
compared to the block shot straight
through its centre how high with the
block shot to one side go now 60% of you
predicted that it wouldn't go as high
didn't seem this high now check out the
high-speed footage oh no you can clearly
see that both for the exact same pace oh
come on 19% said that it would go higher
and only 21% correctly predicted that
both blocks would go to the exact same
height so most of us got it wrong the
first time around and that includes
Henry and me and Destin who has a lot of
experience with this stuff I mean I
can't tell you how many times of it
would would rifle so even experienced
and intelligent people get it wrong
sometimes in this case I think the
result was particularly counterintuitive
because the spinning block clearly ended
up with more energy than the other block
so I asked you guys to make me a video
response and explain what is happening
and this is what I received if you
imagine the bullet traveling through the
center of the block that obstacle
collision
Oh
whoa that is a lot of video responses
and that's not even all of them I've got
to say I was blown away by all of the
great video responses I received you
guys are awesome and I really really
appreciate all the effort you went to
you know some of you actually replicated
the experiment
perhaps with different setups oh the
experiment was featured on blog posts
including Scientific American and wired
there's an interactive simulation you
can try link is in the description and
someone even made a webcomic it is so
incredible you know watching all of
those video responses and I did watch
all of them that was my proudest moment
making this YouTube channel seeing all
of you guys doing science and getting so
involved in putting in so much effort it
just blows my mind it's amazing thank
you guys so much thank you thank you I
can't even put it into words how awesome
it is whoa so what is the answer how
could two identical blocks chalk with
the same rifle end up with different
amounts of energy well some of you felt
that the amount of rotational energy
would be basically insignificant what if
the amount of energy necessary to get
that very small block rotating really is
negligible in comparison to the amount
of energy necessary to lift it into the
air resist gravity well we can calculate
it because the spinning block was
rotating at about 11 times per second so
you can calculate that it's rotational
energy would be equal to 50% of the
gravitational potential energy when
those blocks were at their peak so the
spinning block actually had 1.5 times
the energy of the non rotating block and
in my books that is not negligible so
what else could be causing this well
some of you actually measured the height
difference using pixel counters and
found the blocks didn't go to exactly
the same height so this raises an
important question which is how
different with those Heights have to be
before you can think that there really
is a difference there well given that
the rotational energy is about 50% of
the gravitational potential energy you
might expect the spinning block to go
half as high but looking at the video
footage you can clearly see it doesn't
go half as high
basically to the same height to know for
sure you probably want to do the
experiment a number of times in science
you got to repeat things and make sure
what you saw is not just a fluke that
will happen every time so in fact we did
repeat the experiment a number of times
and here are all of the blocks lined up
side-by-side so you can compare their
heights
the blocks clearly do not all go to the
same height so you might say Derrick you
were tricking us you just pick the two
that went the closest and used those
it's true I did do that but the point is
do the spinning blocks go systematically
to a lower height than the non spinning
blocks and I think from the video
footage the answer is clearly no so why
not
well another common response I saw was
that air resistance must play a role
that the spinning block exposes a
smaller surface area as it's traveling
upwards and this means there's less air
resistance impeding it so even with a
lower velocity it could make it to the
same height as the non spinning block
but you can do the calculation and find
that the difference in air resistance
would be at most about 0.6% of the
weight of the block in other words
negligible so what is the real answer
well there are a number of ways of
approaching the problem and I saw you
guys try almost all of them force torque
momentum energy but the easiest one of
these is the law of conservation of
momentum you see when the bullet is
fired out of the rifle it has a certain
amount of momentum entirely in the
vertical direction and when the bullet
becomes lodged in the block the bullet
and block together must have that same
momentum that the bullet had now it
doesn't matter where on the block the
bullet hits because the bullet had a
certain momentum before it hit the block
the block and bullet together afterwards
must have that amount of momentum
upwards so this means regardless of
whether the block is spinning or not it
must have the same upwards velocity so
that it has the same momentum so we'll
go to the same height regardless of
whether it's spinning or not it is
simple conservation of momentum momentum
is always always conserved it is
something you can always rely on and
it's why you should think about it first
but some of you may say okay well
there's also angular momentum in the
spinning block but the point is angular
momentum and linear momentum are
independent and they're conserved
independently so you can simply think
about the upward momentum of the bullet
and that's going to have to be the
upward momentum of those two blocks and
it doesn't matter that one spinning
because they have the same total linear
momentum upwards so they have to go to
same height but if that is the case why
does the spinning block end up with this
extra rotational energy well the thing
about energy is it's a little bit tricky
although total energy is conserved the
energy of motion which is called kinetic
energy is not conserved so what happens
is as the bullet strikes the wood a lot
of its kinetic energy is lost heating up
the wood creating sound and deforming
that wood block so it will be possible
for the rotating block to end up with
more energy of motion more kinetic
energy if the bullet loses less energy
deforming the wood and heating it up and
creating that sound and this kind of
makes a little bit of intuitive sense
because if you imagine the bullet
entering the block on the side the block
will be moving away from it faster
because it's rotating so that may mean
that the bullet doesn't penetrate in as
far and so it wouldn't lose as much
energy as its entering the wood which
explains why the block has extra energy
allowing it to rotate and go the same
height as the other block let's have a
look at how far in the bullet went into
each block this is our first test here
we go this is the one where I went
straight in there yep now we come over
here to the arson
this is where below in an off-center so
it's not going in here see ya see the
other one okay partway Hansy tomorrow so
the bullet didn't go as far into the
spinning block so that was pretty
convincing evidence but just to be extra
sure we x-rayed both blocks and this is
what we saw I'm going to overlay the
block so we can see the difference in
penetration depth
hang on it looks like both bullets
penetrated each block to the same depth
so does that mean our theory is wrong
well let's think about how different the
bullet deaths should be I mean when the
bullet strikes the block it actually
loses 97% of its original kinetic energy
and the amount of rotational energy the
spinning block has only works out to
about one percent of the original
kinetic energy of the bullet so we would
only expect the difference in depths of
about one percent and for our
measurements that would be about 1/10 of
a millimeter
that would be immeasurable and that is
what we see so although this answer is a
little bit unsatisfying at least it is
the truth as an extra challenge I want
you guys to think about how we could
perhaps modify this experiment so the
difference in bullet depth would be
measurable you can leave your answer in
the comments or make me another video
response because I love those so much
this episode of veritasium was brought
to you by audible.com a leading provider
of audiobooks with over a hundred
thousand titles and all different types
of literature and today I wanted to
recommend a book that changed my life
it's called the 4-hour workweek and it's
by Tim Ferriss who I actually got to
meet this year at VidCon so I read this
book about three years ago when I was
thinking about quitting my job and
starting this YouTube channel and it's
one of the things that contributed to my
decision so if you're thinking about
quitting your job perhaps this is the
book for you
you can actually download it for free by
going to audible.com/veritasium click
the link in the description or you can
choose any other book of your choosing
for a one-month free trial so thanks to
audible for supporting veritasium and
thanks to you for watching